a strike is a targeted strike on the
civilian population, of course this is a
terrorist attack in another way and cannot be called. Should
we respond in this way?
Of course we
can strike
squares in Kiev and in any other
city
where
I have the very Armed Forces whale I want to
ask you we need  do it this way hit the
square No, I’m not saying that to the civilian
population This should be for
military purposes forever They couldn’t come to their senses
and answer us already yes Well that’s what we’re doing,
we
’re hitting with high-precision
weapons in the places where they make
decisions
meme of accumulations of military personnel
in other
centers  this kind of attack on military
targets, first of all, and they are quite
sensitive, these
strikes are what we will do. Did you
notice that literally the next day
such strikes were carried out and today, in my opinion,
and tomorrow we will do business,
they know in the World Cup the meaning of what they
are doing, they want us and  intimidate and B
create some kind of uncertainty in our
country.
Well, for our part, we will increase the
blows that I spoke about and we also want to
end the conflict, and as
quickly as possible, only on our
terms,
we are not going to deny our position. You
fought and were wounded.  there and so on Well,
we’ll ask everything or something. Well, the
camera is working here. I would like to
show a certain gesture now, you all
know what kind of
gesture it is, so this doesn’t
happen in places where
military personnel gather